Sahra martini is relieved to be back
with her college classmates in Berlin
the Syrian refugee an activist was
released on bail after spending more
than three months in a green prison Sara
was returning from lesbos in August when
police arrested her she had spent the
summer volunteering on the Greek island
with a pro refugee organization because
of her work helping migrants authorities
charged her with people smuggling money
laundering and espionage she now faces a
prison sentence of up to 25 years I
never regret anything I've done and
actually I knew deep inside that I've
done that because I wanted to help
people and that's give me motivation her
arrest wasn't the first time that Sarah
made headlines she caught the world's
attention in 2015 but for very different
reasons
she and her sister yo Sarah were making
the perilous sea crossing from Turkey to
lesbos when their dinghy began to take
on water and sink being experienced
swimmers they jumped overboard and
pulled the waterlogged boat to the shore
by doing so they saved the lives of the
18 people on board
they began a new life in Germany yo
syrup became a goodwill ambassador for
the United Nations and was on the
refugee team at the 2016 Rio Olympics so
I want a scholarship to study social
sciences in Berlin but kept on returning
to lesbos to help others I believe when
you fear something just go for it
so I fear the place that I landed in and
I wanted to be on this ground again
following sirs arrest her college
classmates campaigned for her release
organizing protests in Berlin Boston
Athens and other cities her defense team
is calling for greater protection for
humanitarian workers it is an ongoing
conversation right now has to recognize
that has to recognize the criterion of
financial benefit as an obligatory
requirement in order to in order to
establish the crime of migrant smuggling
you cannot have smugglers without
benefits and this is obvious you have to
exclude from sanctions people and
organizations that provide humanitarian
aid until such safeguards are in place
Greek authorities can claim that Sarah
was helping migrants enter the country
illegally she's currently waiting for
her case to go to trial she hopes it
won't go that far
but is determined to prove her innocence
and that saving lives is not a crime